first of all I want to say congrats on
the movie I really emotionally connected
it is very familiar to a story My Own
Story I just want to say very congrats
extremely well done thank you very much
thank you that means a lot but I want to
start with the most important thing what
does is it going to take for Pixar to
make a Star Blazers movie
[Laughter]
oh man uh I'm with you on that one like
there's so many of that era for me that
I would love to see on the big screen a
thousand percent I think you and I need
to start a fund I think we need to start
a fund now that can start to grow into a
movement because that I think that's the
only way to get that triggered I mean
Star Blazers Robotech Force 5 grandizer
which generation of Robotech yeah right
but like I can give you a list I'm just
wonder anyway I'm obviously messing
around I'm gonna take the Jane Austen
version of an animated film
um so being serious one of the things
that I really respected about this is
that your two lead voices are not named
Chris Pratt and you know Gal Gadot like
you went with real voices rather than
like celebrity casting obviously they're
people you know I'm not trying to right
not but you know what I mean they're not
like huge names that would go on Good
Morning America you know um so can you
talk about that aspect because I found
it great
um so much of the Journey of this film
has come from a very sincere place you
know like in terms of wanting to thank
our parents I know that's a weird reach
to come into the uh the voices but like
even when looking for the voices it was
a very sincere thing I really was
looking for two pieces of a performance
that supported the character and it's a
little bit of the element
um I'm sort of not and uh for Leah you
know she did this tremendous uh
performance in a movie called the half
of it where she showed a fierceness
you know as she's discovering her
identity and then this tenderness at the
same time for her family that I I
thought a character like Amber needed
but she has a smoky voice like when she
sings There's a smoky quality to it that
you know immediately connected me to it
outside of celebrities or whatever just
like oh that felt so sincerely Ember and
the same for Mamadou uh watching him
into the several performances where you
could feel his sort of go with the flow
attitude there was this movie called the
um Uncorked where he was sort of
flirting with someone but he just moved
in and out of that and selling the wine
as his character was doing effortlessly
and that brought me to this like oh my
gosh could you do that and then uh Avi
Wade cries a lot in this movie and uh I
had heard a lot of different performers
crying and there was all this very flat
sort of pinching thing that sort of hurt
after a while but he did this thing on
uh oh Jerome nowhere he found
a goofy version of it but it was still
sincere and then a really dramatic
version of it that was still totally
brought you and pulled you in and it was
all those pieces that just said you know
what yeah they are really these
characters but that's a I mean that's
it's a good question because it's a it
is you know you do you have to think
about that right and ultimately I I mean
I do love that we get the support of
what's what's the best thing for the
actual film right right and and that's
that's what I feel we we were lucky to
settle upon I'm always listen I know
about the editing process and so much
changes with an animated movie
especially so talk a little bit about
what it was like showing it for the
first time to like the executives or
friends and family and what did you
learn from that screening that
ultimately impacted the finished film
um that's a good one there's so many
screenings we've had so many one but a
big one for me was that like my parents
passed away during the making of this
thing and the the story took a dark turn
like I didn't even know that it was you
know like and these things don't just
aren't like a push button thing to make
it you know the process they take months
and months and uh I was filtering
something dark through this like there
was a war between the father and a
daughter that was just like so spiteful
and uh um uh after that screening I
remember having conversations with a lot
of the support around here doctor
executive producer was just like hey
Pete I know you're going through it was
this the film that you always wanted to
do and uh um no I've always uh you know
you were therapy like this was always a
hopeful thing that we were doing and um
I remember him going like you know
there's a lot that you're going through
that we can feel in the film and uh you
know you know you're gonna need some
time to and from after that moment a lot
of the ideas
I came back to
I'm sorry I'm gonna get emotional slug
anyways
it it just uh um
every
invigorated the original heart to this
thing and then that film started
becoming what we finished I mean those
screenings end up being really important
like because you we yeah I mean as
Pete's alluding to we sort of lose our
way and so sometimes you know bringing
in that fresh audience at the time like
I'm always amazed like are people gonna
still laugh are they gonna still connect
and so that that's why those are really
important I would say throughout our
process is bringing those people in one
of the things that I also really enjoyed
is that you don't have I expected there
to be a villain at some point Who's you
know stopping them from doing something
in actuality there is no villain it's
just life and it's about family and
relationships and I found that so
refreshing can you talk about that
aspect yeah
um we did have a Villain at one time
um in the middle I think it was it
wasn't connected to that dark version
but uh
um once we went down that route the
whole studio missed the point of it
meaning like they almost like oh what
happened to the connection between these
because there's so much Exposition you
have to do with something like that and
uh again it was about coming back to the
original intent about about connection
and what could happen between fire and
water and so then that version went away
and then we just focused on what does it
mean and how to exploit
a relationship between fire and water
like that if you don't mind I'm going to
ask a technical question one of the
things listen every Pixar movie has the
craziest fnet animation I'm always
sitting there just looking at it and
mesmerized but I would imagine each film
there's these technical challenges or
new software you need to invent so what
were some of the things that you were up
against on this one that you had to
write new code or there was new
technical things that have never been
overcome it was definitely the two
characters we had um you know because
their their simulations we had no
pipeline at all to create these
characters and Pete was really emphatic
about them being the actual element and
not being a person on fire like Jack
Jack so that would set us on a course
that we had to kind of add a department
we spent a lot of time doing
experimentation and iteration to you
know because they still we want them to
feel like fire but the you know a
realistic fire character could be
fatiguing to watch and maybe not that
appealing so
um the characters we we we worked with a
Disney's research group in Zurich a lot
of smart people working many many many
months doing a lot of experimentation
and iteration yeah in the game of those
experiments we're really trying to just
control it yeah give us some tools to
control the flame because the you know
when they first push the button on her
she looked terrifying she looked like a
character from The Lord of the Rings she
was just this monster that was just and
real fire is so busy and but the
technology that he's talking about from
Zurich just like
held it and then we kept we fought it
most of the time but that was that it
was that technology I mean we worked on
the way way the water character ended up
being so much more complicated water is
always harder and that continued to
prove to be the case yeah weed was a
monster he was just awful the whole way
like you know he the lighting of him
changed in every shot because like in
the basement he would disappear because
there's no light bouncing off of him and
then when he was in sunlight on the
rooftop he would just glow like this
gigantic Spotlight and uh every sequence
he was just this
Maniac of of look look we didn't have
those issues like inside out we're
inside out like oh
um emotions could be anything there is
no look but everyone knows what fire and
water looks like and there are moments
where Wade could look like jelly just by
moving one ingredient that was too slow
or something or he could look like a
ghost immediate you know like we're just
changing one little layer he was a
monster I think on the Blu-ray you
should include some sort of Sizzle where
you um you know demonstrate some of
these things oh yeah oh yeah there's
plenty of that there's a lot uh on that
note I gotta go I'm just gonna say
congrats hope is a huge hit for you guys